[Applause]
excellencies ladies and gentlemen a very
good afternoon to you all it's a great
pleasure and privilege for me to welcome
you all the Karolinska Institutet owl
america for the 2016 nobel lecture in
Physiology or medicine my name is Colin
Dharma right and I serve as acting vice
chancellor of Karolinska Institutet
during the noble week and particularly
during the noble lectures we celebrate
science and the unique contributions of
some exceptional individuals research is
a way of exploring our source for
knowledge testing our own limits and
having outlet for our creativity and
competitive spirit within Physiology or
medicine the ultimate goal is to achieve
scientific breakthroughs a change our
view of human health disease and normal
vital processes to the benefit of
individuals as well as society at large
today it's an only for me to extend my
warmest welcome on behalf of the carrion
sky instituted to Yoshinori assuming the
2016 Nobel laureate in Physiology or
medicine who is receiving the Nobel
Prize for elucidating mechanism and the
light on the lying a tough OG a
fundamental process for degrading and
recycling cellular components I now call
upon Maria Masucci professor of Urology
and a member of the Nobel Committee for
Physiology or medicine who will
introduce the low rate
[Applause]
dear Nobel laureate acting
vice-chancellor colleagues ladies and
gentlemen it's a great privilege and an
honor for me to introduce this year's
Nobel lecture by Nobel laureate
Yoshinori assuming the Nobel assembly at
Karolinska Institute has awarded the
2016 Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine to dr. sue me for his
discoveries on the mechanism of how tofo
gene out of a G which means literally
self eating is an evolutionary conserved
across physiological process by which a
eukaryotic cells digest the part of
their own content to release energy or
to recycle the building blocks that are
required for the production of proteins
sugars and fats out of a gene was first
observed more than 50 years ago shortly
after the discovery by a Christian de
Duve of the lysosome the lysosome is the
recycling compartment on the cells where
cellular component are actually
destroyed and Christian de Duve received
for his discovery the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine in 1974 while
studying the lysosome scientists
discovered another part vesicle in the
cells which is sequestered into a double
strand double layer membrane parts of
the cytoplasm and large components such
as protein aggregates and an organelle
using a different type of visualization
method the fractionation procedures they
could also observe that vesicles appear
in the cytoplasm of cells which are
exposed to different type of stress and
that this vesicle Groot engulfed parts
of the cytoplasm and finally fused to
the lysosome
where their content is destroyed for
almost 30 years very few scientists
studied out of a gym and in fact the
molecular mechanism of this phenomenon
is significance remain largely unknown
the discoveries of your Tenorio swimming
changed dramatically this field of
research he for his studied focused on a
unicellular organism the baker's yeast
and discovered first of all that the
auto Fujii is conserved in this organism
and can be easily visualized in a simple
organism like this one cell or organ he
then went on to develop a very clever
screening method that allowed to
identify a large number of genes that
are essential for the development of
Altaf AG and subsequently he and his
colleagues went on to a list de the
function of the product of these genes
which at the end both in yeast and in
mammalian cells which are the Enda led
to a very comprehensive view of the
mechanism of philology and which allowed
further understanding or the importance
of this phenomenon for both physiology
and disease we are now very much looking
forward to hear from Professor Sumi
himself the history of how scientific
curiosity hardwork and endurance have
led to our current understanding of
autophagy
as a fundamental psychological process
with the huge implication for both
health and disease but before giving the
world to Professor assuming I would like
to say a few words on the Nobel laureate
himself
Yoshinori Osumi was born in Fukuoka
Japan in 1945 and he receives it is a
doctoral degree from the University of
Tokyo in 1974 after a postdoctoral
training at the Rockefeller University
in New York
he returned to Tokyo University were
installed too slowly to climb they and
academic career ladder being first an
assistant professor scientist a lecturer
and assistant professor in 1996 he was
appointed professor at the National
Institute of basic research in Okazaki
city and from 94 2004 to 2009 he was
also professor at the Graduate
University West and advanced studied in
Hama he officially retired in 1914 but
is still working full-time and I
understand also during a holiday during
weekends and when he is currently
serving as a professor at Tokyo
University Institute of Technology where
he had a sir biology research unit the
outstanding work of Professor Liu Sumi
has been recognized by many different
prizes and just to mention a few we
received a Tokyo prize for basic science
in 2012 the Gardner foundation award in
2015 and only a few days ago he received
a breakthrough prize in life sciences we
really look forward to dr. Uzume and
Noble lecture with the title al-tofah G
and intercellular recycling system and
please join me in welcoming professor
sue me on stage
[Applause]
okay it's late on attitude for me to be
here as a recipient of Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine first
I would like to express my sincere
appreciation to calorie sky student
Nobel foundation for this wonderful
opportunity and I would like to say
thank to all the audience here today
let's begin
I believe sis now science is a system of
knowledge that is gradually accumulated
by society but it's also in Helen Terry
human activity I believe that every
scientist is a product of the error day
which in deep so today I would like to
start my talk from a brief introduction
of my life then give us historical
overview of our work I was born oh sorry
I was born in Fukuoka southern Japan
Japan in 1945 half years before the end
of World War two that this was a very
tiny time in Japan and everyone had
difficulty getting basic basic daily
necessities including food I myself
suffered severe malnutrition and was was
the belly sick each child and this time
my mother got tuberculosis and heather
was the belly spent a long time period
but bed-bound
sorry but she was miraculously able to
recover thank to the gifts of just
developed antibiotics from the family
friend in Hawaii I remembered the word
streptomycin and all the amazing without
knowing what did that mean my childhood
were homeless surrounded by nature with
rice paddies streams hills and sea all
nearby I spent a lot of time outside
catching a fish and peaking plants in
elementary school I was engrossed in
collecting insects and watching night
sky I would say this intimacy for nature
had a strong influence on me at that
time
I beg Li long to be a scientist in high
school I joined to the chemistry club
club where I experienced the wonder of
chemical reactions I entered the
University of Tokyo where I initially
hoped to be a chemist soon but soon I
had difficulty to find a field to work
in sank free this was a time when
central dogma was just been established
molecular biology immediately fascinated
me so I decided to join the love of
calamari mihari as a graduate student
there I began my research career
studying ly Besson which is a machinery
of protein synthesis this period made me
Hindi aware of the continuous nature of
protein synthesis with himself I
gradually become interested in the
Uncharted function by a membrane so I
worked on the mechanism
action of collision history which is a
cytotoxic protein that inhibitor protein
synthesis by binding a receptor on the
membrane of other cells after finishing
my doctorate studies I unloved in the
lab of Gerald Edmond at Rockefeller
University New York their fire during my
final year in dr. Edmunds lab I worked
with Mikey Olinsky on the initiation
mechanism of DNA replication in East
which was my first encounter with East
as I experimental organism at the end of
94 77 I returned to Japan as of
assistant professor in yes a hero and I
his lab at the University of Tokyo dr.
Umbach is aid and tailor was tasked with
study and transporters and respiratory
chain in e.coli but fortunately he
allowed me to start his work after a
period of reflection I decided to work
on the East bacio I'm not a competitive
person but rather prefer to work on the
subject that is not fashionable this am
picture shoulder east bacio you don't
see any structure inside about you at
that time vacuole so just a sorry it's
no more than the garbage dump in the
cell but I thought it must pray yet
unknown role in cell physiology and I
was able to show active transports of
amino acid and calcium iron through the
back yo membrane providing evidence
that backhoe is important for
homeostasis of metabolites and the ions
we also described the novel plottin pump
on the back eyo membrane we type ATPase
which generates a proton gradient across
the membrane back eyo membrane in 1988 I
was able to start my own lab consisting
just myself at the College of Arts and
Sciences at the University of Tokyo I
decided to devote myself to
oolitic function of espacio since it is
a acidic compartment and contain various
hydrolytic enzymes so I thought it might
be homologous to lysosome however I had
no concrete idea how to approach this
problem before going to experiment or
deep details I would briefly touch on
protein mechanic metabolism in cell
proteins which are the polymer of amino
acid the key player in all biological
processes central dogma stated that the
plot in his sin site according their
genetic information encoded in DNA
through RNA since then many researchers
have studied how to understand such gene
expression and protein synthesis recent
progress in cell biology has revealed
how each protein localized to its
specific destination in the cell we know
now each protein is ingeniously
organized through the process of
intracellular trafficking however one
aspect that is missing from this picture
was their degradation of protein within
cell when I held
College across for first-year
undergraduate student I used to start my
lecture with this question how many
blood cells are made within just one
second in our body
calculation is simple and given an
answer about 3 million cell per second
how about hemoglobin within that blood
cell for the calculation showed that
about 1 times 10 to the 15 1 medium
median hemoglobin molecules inside per
second it felt that exactly the same
amount of cells and proteins are
degraded the key message is that living
cells are so dynamically maintained
Japanese climate is characterized by
four distinct reasons that influence our
culture and student at school and that
everything are continuously changing
front ribs of offer an excellent example
in spring raves developed and then
actively synthesized search by sunlight
but in autumn leaves turn yellow and
fall off what we see as a beautiful of
autumn color is actually caused by the
degradation of leaves photosynthetic
machinery green for chloroplasts are
completely degraded and resulting amino
acid or transport to the trunk
similary lie sleep turn yellow at
harvest time all protein in the ribs are
delayed and transported to make fruit
proteins in rice grain for next
generation these examples demonstrate
that
regulation is not adverse process but
rather it's essential for new
construction or degeneration but think
about the human body our body make about
two to three hundred grams of protein
every day but we only intake about 70 to
80 grams of protein for from the diet
the amine acid required for protein
synthesis mostly come from the
degradation of our body's own proteins
life is maintained tightly control
balance between synthesis and
degradation and recycling the essential
for life early pioneer in the field of
protein makeup metabolism was the dog
sharing himer who in 90s thirties
proposed the concept of protein turnover
however unfortunately his idea was not
widely accepted the monumental
breakthrough come from come in the 1950s
with the discovery of rice alone by
christian boo boo soon after researchers
at Rockefeller University analyzed the
process of the delivery of our own Zahra
component to lysosome by electron
microscopy a process which Christians do
coined or thathe G in 94 262 from the
Greek for self eating bland multi mer
and the Parseghian afterward produced
informative works by tackling both
historical meaning and regulation about
tofu Jeon in mammals
despite this our standing understanding
the molecular mechanism all tough OG
remain in its infancy for many years a
month mean in the meantime
another intracellular protein
degradation system your extreme
protostomes system was discovered as it
become clear that the system praise
important roles on the integration of a
variety of cellular process protein
degradation suddenly attracted huge
amount of attention in biological
research this was ultimately recognized
by the Nobel Prize in Chemistry in 2004
but was awarded which was awarded to the
three scientists shown here but the
field of rhizome degradation and
autophagy still remained quiet now that
they turned to my work
assuming that the back eyo function or
the ready compartment the question I had
were well what and how sat/rad mcwho
constituent go across the back your
membrane and become accessible to back
your enzymes first I searched what
condition we must wear massive protein
degradation made my token yeast cell
life cycle spur formation is a mating
process that generate for spores and is
induced by the depletion of nitrogen the
essential element for amino acid I
reasoned that this dramatic sorority
modelling should requires degradation of
pre-existing protein to make necessary
proteins I had to admit that I have
always loved to absorb each cell by
light microscopy the black yo is
relatively large and it's only clear
clearly visible or vanilla in the cell
and the inside of the back yo is just a
solid solution so I knew that it is easy
to
see structure if they were inside the
vacuum I probably spend more time
sitting at the microscope than anyone
else at that time I carefully observed
the Anastasia sporulation
but I couldn't see any significant
change in the cell I conceived to use
herbal Eve Accura protein is deficient
Milton to blow prevent further
degradation fortunately that is arrested
Jones had their donated many protein is
mutant in two East genetic stock center
so I obtained these strange and shifted
to the nitrogen depleted medium looking
down the microscope
I saw many Stryker structure vigorously
moving on the vacuum this structure
appeared within 30 minutes and almost
completely filled the vacuum after three
to four hours for me this observation
matter exactly starting point for more
than 27 years of Altaf AG research the
reason I could discover this phenomena
with only a common low magnification by
microscopy or to the vigorous movement
of this structure by blood evolving
emotion in otherwise stuck East cells
this dramatic change was enough to
convince me that I encountered that
unknown and fascinating phenomena soon
kazuhiko takeshiba
showed this phenomena is not risky the
typical variation but it's a general
thorough response to a range of
starvation nutrient starvation condition
then I called a excellent electron
microscopist mr. Baba and a Sapporo semi
to capture the morphology of this
phenomena within cell by electron
microscopy their effort produced
beautiful and conclusive image of that
entire autophagy process as shown in the
South following several slide this 16
section image of nitrogen stops cell up
for three hours you can see circle
structure within vacuole and this high
magnification image hold these structure
are bounded by a single membrane and
their contents are exactly the same as a
portion of site Pradhan sites outside
plasmic structures such as ER here
suggesting a non-selective registration
of site brand component we also observe
the membrane suck just and not being
apportioned besides so next to the
backhoe after completion of expansion
and sealing we could see the double
membrane structure of East of Ferguson
and this fracture image showed a fusion
event between both phagosome with Bakula
membrane their outer membrane about
phagosome is continuous with ocular
membrane here also you can see in a
membrane structure which we named all
tragic bodies automatic body is body
occasionally contain mitochondria
schon servers yeah here and here and
here so that means a logic Auto Foggia
can degrade not on these sites or
protein but also super molecular
structure like ribosome and even entire
organelle which is a characteristic
characteristic feature about tougher G
this slide shows the scheme of ultra
hjek philosophy nice when cells are
faced with starvation condition small
membranes are appear next to the vacuole
and expand to an upper possible
cytoplasm then double membrane structure
or follow some targets the back.you and
shoes with pakhi or membrane releasing
in in a membrane structure into the
vacuum in one type so this structure
immediately disrupted by Bakula enzyme
the protein is deficient mutants allowed
us to follow the progression of all
tougher gr the accumulation of all trans
bodies the membrane dynamics of this
process was essentially the same as
known memory and all tough OG though
baku is much larger than lysosome as you
know East is a very good organ to
dissection for dissection of complicated
biological phenomena through genetic
analysis I was inspired by Bill who
worked by the Heart Walk which unlocked
the cell cycle from through CDC mutant
and also by uncovering of a circulatory
pathway using sec mutant by Lundy
sheckman I therefore set out to obtain
outfit effective Milton to find the gene
involved in orthology
however
at that time I had no idea how autophagy
defective mutant would behave so we
decided to perform a simple Malecha
screening for mutant that do not
accumulate automatic body under
starvation condition Mickey SCADA one of
them my first graduate student made a
great contribution during this screening
process by assessing 4000 of mutagen I'd
sell by one one by one for mutant
dragging automatic body see she
identified the first autophagy defective
mutant which we named a PG 1-1 later
renamed to ATG one this mutant so this
mutant cannot proceed protein
degradation but they grew no Murray in
which made him and otherwise had no
obvious phenotype however soon we found
that 81 mutant die sooner than wild-type
so during long period of starvation
shown here assuming that this phenotype
is called by the defecting Auto Fuji
Mickey
run another screen of assessing the
viability of mutagenize cell first and
successfully obtained about 100 100
autophagy defect mutant genetics
analysis of this mutant we build 14 ATG
mutant we know now eighteen eighty g
genes are essential for starvation in
this sort of a Jeannie's so I can say
this initial screen was very effective
soon our work by electron microscopy
suggested that all these occasions are
defective in the formation about of our
film the most crucial event in notify G
the first the next step was to determine
protein encoded by these ATG genes the
first gene ATG one turned out to to
encode protein kinase but most of eighty
genes from by our group and the others
were completely noble and I mean as the
sequence of did not tell us anything
about their function that was a
difficult time for us my love in courage
of art and science was quite small and
had no fancy equipment funding was
limited and I had only a few colleagues
but it was doubt that that eight years
in that lab were the foundation of my
work in autophagy
in 1996 I became a professor at the
National Institute of asic biology in
Okazaki which provide us with a very
conducive researcher environment
I asked thomas yoshimori to join our lab
as associate professor to start working
out of a gene mummers mammalian cell and
also
takeshi Noda and yoshika mother to join
us as our seasoned professors the
following year noble Mishima came into
my lab as a postdoc year by year
talented postdoc there are researchers
and the graduate student
to my lab the cloning of 80 genes
proceed much faster than I expected
the Sun to the collaboration of
molecules image lab and also completion
of East general genome project the first
breakthrough was done by noble Mishima
when he examined the products of ATG 12
he found two bands one of which runs
much high molecular weight
he also layered in Wow
he also found in ATG 5 7 and 10 these
high molecular weight band is missing I
want to go further detail we found that
ATG 12 is a novel we became like more
like you and it's activated by even
enzyme ATG 7 then transfer to 882 enzyme
a t10 and finally our firm bound with 82
5 to 2 and finally this 80 12 5
conjugate is is bound by ATG said if 16
dimers this discovery of the discovery
of this enzyme system uncovered the
function of 580 gene that all at once
under molecule we are interested in was
a TG 8 because immuno electron
microscopy showed that 88 is local to
the auto generated membrane as shown
here
suggesting that the good marker for
membrane biogenesis to talented graduate
student Takahashi Achilles akan Yoshino
Ichimura unveiled another unique
conjugation system a tg8 is since acid
as a precursor that is processed by a
TGIF ATG for protein ease and it's
activated by the same even enzyme 87 and
then transferred to 83 but rather
forming with a conjugate with protein 88
form the bomb with one of the major
membrane phospholipid
phosphatidylethanolamine thus out to our
supplies we found about half of ATG
genes are involved in to these
conjugation systems in 1998 Caucasian
order found that promising uses the auto
fiji even that are grown in a rich
medium as lap amaizing the inhibitor
brokenness which therefore propyl token
token is is the most upstream regulator
voltage e meantime yoshika mother and
Tomoko Nkosi studied the arrest of auto
fuji and showed EDG 13 and 17 played an
important role in aught of as induction
and necessary 481 kinase activation
Kahala
Akio Kahala also found the autophagy
requires basic
pi3 kinase complex one which is distinct
from the predominant
complex 8/9 complex to within a decade
of our researching in an MDB we found
two more 80 g protein got in trust each
other as well at 80 17 that we regulate
81 kinase activity we concluded
that total 1880 protein are essential
for the physique and those protein can
be classified into six functional groups
shown here
ATG one kinase complex unregulated ATG
pi3 kinase complex - conjugation system
and 89 Sol membrane protein among ATG in
and a TD - ATG 18 complex also during my
our time at ni BB novel mizushima
yoshimori automata yoshimori began to
study memory on auto Fuji and
successfully showed that a t12 system
well conserved in mammalian cell and
Tamotsu definitely diffic difficult ibly
proved that a LCC a tg8 homologue can be
used as a very effective marker or both
of as a progression immemorial cell but
along this time two of my colleague two
colleagues Hideki Hana Aconcagua shamoto
succeeded to identify 80 genes in plants
so although the homology of ATG genes
are all but ATG system is well consumed
from is to mammoth and plan indicating
that the core machinery award Hadji are
acquired at an early stage of evolution
the identification of ATG jeans
essential for tough OG change the entire
landscape of auto veggie research one
except us
tech table this aberration is that we
can now be here the process of all tough
OG by Versalles microscopy using hg g
protein asthma
kurz nobleman semantic advantage about
this when he constructed a transgenic
Mouse expressing gfp lc3 his to was
allowed to us to excel assess how much
autofocus in every organ in most body
this mouse has been distributed all over
the world
noburo also developed at first
ATG one knockout mouse and which allowed
to show auto fuzzy praise the crucial
role for Habiba at birth and Komatsu
misaki Komatsu shoulder by user making a
conditional 87 knockout mouse he showed
their auto fuji is essential for
defective mutant accumulate or
originated protein fire ultimately tumor
in the liver from this point
manipulation roid eighty genes in
various organ is different cell type
variety petitioned organs and the
individuals studied in many rods around
the world and revealed a burst alley of
physiological function of autophagy the
relevance of autophagy in various
diseases are getting cleared this rapid
expansion of all tough OG would not have
been possible without a concerted effort
of Auto Hadji research all over the
world but this huge area fall outside
the scope of my talk today I mentioned
earlier the nutrient recycling is the
most creamy primary functionable to
she's a variational dapped a Shinto a
persistent challenge of from nutrient
limitation starvation recent work has
shown that another important function of
autophagy in addition to the bulk
recycling of portion of site frozen atre
G is also able to pick and choose excess
or ham who metier from the site frozen
in a selective manner target of this the
degradation includes specific protein
super molecular structure protein
aggregate organelle and even virus and
invasive bacteria now it is well
accepted that author Hadji plays an
essential role to maintenance of the
server homeostasis affecting this
quality control may cause various
abnormality health problem and disease
this kind of auto AG is generally not
random and but selective also using
yeast Dan crayons key has studied CBD
pathway the first identified model
system of selective altough AG in these
several receptor for selective Auto
Hadji has been found as shown here in
now versus selected modo both of us has
become one of the most exciting field in
autophagy research we are now beginning
to arrive at the clear understanding -
for some of these four active types of
auto AG such as mitochondria Auto fuzzy
but this is an area in which we need
more research to obtain the precise
molecular details even in simple East
system
many fundamental questions remain to be
answered for this reason my group is
still working on East altough AG
although we have identified the core
component of auto focus on formation the
question of where and how this protein
function in the cell remained
Kanuri suzuki made a major contribution
on this area first he found that altough
AG is induced most ad g-protein blockers
at least partly a dot structure next to
the back yoke he also showed that earth
phagosome is generated from these dot
structures we called proud to have some
structure the past we systematically
analyzed the mutual relationship between
a TD protein to uncover the how the pass
is organized and found the causal
relationship among six functional groups
as shown in this slide
87 82 113 complexes of row and then 89
comes something like that okay and
recent improvement of them fluorescent
microscopy what Wow sorry
I made a mistake
yeah listen microscope showed this is a
ATG 17 that means a dimer form of ATG 17
29:31 complex as you see here ATG 17 is
just moving around in the cytosol and
the great growing condition oh sorry
well what's happened sorry
what should I do
toy that won't work some help me
sorry which could you help me
okay
okay so sorry and the starvation
condition ad I was sorry under
starvation condition our small person of
87 17 complex come to the past as shown
here that means only a portion of
protein doing auto focus on formation
and the starvation conditions but now we
know that he'll articles relationship
between 80 g protein different the
temporal sequence of events that occur
during also information shown here close
and long-term collaboration is not know
born order and the late dr. Rioja Cohen
Adachi successfully provide us with
structural information of many ATG
protein and their complex which was very
crucial for our understanding of their
function now I'd like to talk briefly
about the recent work on re step aboard
for some formation which were mostly
done by Hayashi AMA motor and Noble
another ATG certain is a key prayer that
has which has a quite unique structure
that is made in the tamil robert domain
and the rest is just a long denature
natural disorder region in this region
we can found many phosphorylated residue
by talk kinase and the starvation these
it is searching residual of quickly
display phosphorylated which allowed to
bound to 81 and 87 team via specific
site in disorder region resulting the
formation of dimer weight is 1 13 17 29
31 complex as you see here we found
their specific binding site of 18 13 281
and also we could identify their binding
site of 1817 to the ATG 13 and in the
region of disordered region so it is 13
that were first hydrated it is her team
can bound ATG 7 1 and 18 17 29 31
complex but then Korean skis group
showed real actual number of 80 protein
at the past is about 30 to 40 so next
question we have is how is high higher
order the structure is formed recently
we found another binding site of 1817 in
the disorder region and I wish holder
our image of their hardest step of all
or thousand for a formation as I said it
is her team has wrong disorder region
and after the phosphorylation of this
residue allowed to bound to ATG one
kinase at and thermos and this region is
a binding site of a TD 17 it formed this
kind of complex and we found another
binding site of 1817 it's bound to
another ATG this complex so that our
to the forming or higher order of this
structure that means we can have more
[Music]
multimeric form of this 81 complex this
is important for activation of ATG one
kinase these adjacent 81 by this was our
auto phosphorylation and also we found
recently shows the key shoulder it is
here and terminal domain bound to the 89
89 to recruit 89 basically so this is
our image of the step above Auto Fuji or
travel formation so this result shoulder
80 pass is not static
our stable complex and posses flexible
super molecular assembly made up many
ATG complex and also membrane structure
and as a assembly is also highly
regulated by modification and transient
interaction of 80 protein at each stage
of membrane formation okay now at
present my group is focused on the
physiological meaning about of a gene
yeast in a way I feel we have come full
circle by going back to the original
question when and how and what is
degraded by Auto Fuji by using a latest
analytical tools from Han and Tomoko
Kurata
showed that massive RNA is degraded by
autophagy and the resulting base
transport out from the cell it's not
recycling system so I believe we need
more knowledge about the degradation
process and also assess the degradation
product of the auto physique and how
they are transported out from the barrio
to the site broaden and how they affect
the Magnus sarah metabolism so those are
question we are trying to so my ultra G
research has always been driven by
nothing more than intellectual curiosity
and such to get greater understanding of
life through protein the protein
dynamics in the cell when I started my
work I never sold auto Hadji becomes so
relevant to disease as diverse as neuro
degeneration infected infectious disease
cancer and others in such a short time
but now autophagy research has become a
major field in biology and this figure
presents that the number of paper
related autophagy is so rapidly
increasing it goes without saying that
this is this is thanks to the large part
to the tremendous work effort of many
researchers all over the world so I'd
like to express my sincere thanks to
share this honor with all of them
however this figure also tells us it
takes a while to as
which one field truly the original
discovery in science are often triggered
by unpredictable and unforeseen small
findings
nowaday distance between basic discovery
and practical application is getting
closer while it is exciting but
scientists are now increasingly required
to provide evidence of immediate and
tangible application of their work it is
true truly my hope that society is able
to nurture not only purpose oriented of
science but also hands as a core of
culture rock activity if my small idea
and the case of work had made a
contribution to fundamental science
through Auto Fiji and Noble Foundation
they cannot the basic nature of this
work with this prize is on history my
great pleasure and satisfaction as a
basic scientist finally how I must
acknowledge all all good fortune I had a
berth throughout my career the excellent
colleagues who has joined me on this
journey
great effort of many collaborators good
friend and continued support of many
grants and my caring family especially
my wife Marie colt
thank you for attention
[Applause]